welcome to this video the group what the
gladiator P i okay I haven't decided yet
what to do okay I can do something funky
yeah it's not very very exciting yeah
you know can I do something I have the
knight on f6 already during this recent
open tournament that I played there was
a funny game where this is a piano from
a Romanian not German grim awesome
played quick aged five in a situation
maybe let's let's put let's go for that
see if I can irritate him a bit okay I
play it for baby I'll do it
this is it looks very crude of course
but it's not that pointless okay he's
totally totally not reacting to it okay
see intending to play FTX if he takes
with the F pawn and no it's not okay
Bishop to g4 is blundering a piece
unfortunately maybe just Bishop to e6
and 27 and Bishop f3 I mean in my book I
just have an open H file against the
king isn't this dangerous like really
dangerous
maybe this wasn't so forceful but I is
really relaxed about all that hmm
okay so hmm
okay well b5 is a move definitely but
okay let's see b5 I mean I also have
let's think about it I can take with
Bishop h3 is something that will come
anyway I can take this in any case yeah
okay takes you know there should be
eight looks passive yeah yeah but why
not why not
Bishop h3 is something that is in the
position anyway and I mean it's coming I
don't mind any we can take on c7 take 8
and so on but it's going to your
checkmate it then I don't know this is
at least dangerous thing okay I'm going
to do that now check
yeah okay let's see Queen where to f5
and then you form maybe I cannot take on
g2 right giving up no
yeah I wonder I wonder 26 not sure where
to put that Queen f3 is a move that I'm
not sure about I cannot play not a
bishop before again due to to turn the
night hmm
yeah yeah yeah he somehow is defended
here it's not that that much of a
problem the whole thing fam he do I go
f5 I guess yeah I'm not in a better in a
bad situation here but I rethought um I
should have an even better position
maybe just my my general optimism about
things but okay maybe I can if you use
this rook here one of the son I know
that this looks like a very sad Bishop
in v8 but I want to go night night away
and c6 Knight d7 maybe here it makes a
little bit more sense here even because
after 97 I can think of taking on c3 80
he's got Queen d7 awesome
never I can still do it
who I'm in one minute 35 that's 5th it's
important okay
and I need to recognize that the bishop
on the long diagonal is preventing stuff
like before which in other situations
could be a good idea if I before to cut
the Queen on the long diagonal but the
bishop on c3 is always looking at the
rook okay at the moment he has to think
about his pieces being somewhat somewhat
tight tied to one another okay yeah okay
I'm going to take it I mean no okay
Queen trade huh I don't know about that
I can't I have no realistic attack
anyway anymore but here okay come on I
think my king is now involved maybe
Bishop e7 b6 can be an idea and the rook
to the FO interesting position a good
thing is that he is also taking some
time
this is intending to double on the AFR
ultimately maybe also rook a form
something like that rook a age group a
44 okay interesting
yeah I'm going to use this maybe I can
get the d5 pawn yeah this would be
really nice okay time warning I know no
blundering there blundering c7 I'm such
a [ __ ] giving away the whole game here
from a totally good position no come on
impossible I'm such an idiot
check even so maybe major I think I even
get checkmated here unbelievable
check
check check check check check check
draw he just repeated ah yeah this was
really bad I mean yeah like it's just a
little bit better but I what did i do
him yeah maybe I should have taken I
don't know I'm not taking his easy a
mirage yeah I this was just bad player
this is this is just bad repaid I was
thinking I was thinking that I can go
this yeah and then trade like I did in
the game but I completely forgot that
here I mean this is just a total blunder
I totally forgot that after this trade
this rook is also attacking here so I'm
just really bad I am okay so I should
take care yeah and I should have thought
about this form I should have thought
about this phone because it's pretty
clear that it would will go like this
and now something like this just wins
the pawn right away now this is
excellent for black I'm winning this and
after that I even have the better bond
structure now with c6 I can can put up a
very sturdy structure then rook a8 rook
a four and so on is is very very nice
for black ah not good yeah and here this
this is rook Aegis is giving it away
brilliant yeah I mean and I think maybe
I missed some chances earlier Jack yeah
I don't know it was probably okay I just
shouldn't play this nonsense at the end
okay well thanks for watching